Okay now we want to connect up our
button the way we did for the label.
First let's make a little room for the
button by moving this label up a bit.
And we'll need to open up our utilities
pane so we can drag in the button.
There we go while we have this
utilities pain on the right open
let's go ahead and
set the titles on this button and label.
To do that you're going to want to
go to the attributes inspector and
then you can see here's
where our Title gets set.
We'll just say Click.
And then for the label let's just
set its original text to zero.
Let's close our Utilities pane for
now and move this back to the center.
And next up we're going to set
the target action on this button.
First up, let's open up our
View Controller file for
a little review on target actions.
Recall that the target action
that we added programmatically
had three key components.
Its target which was self, the action
which was the method increment count,
and the event that would trigger
that action touch up inside.
So now we're going to use
storyboard to tie together these
same three pieces of information.
But first, we need to mark this method
as a IB action, so that it actually
shows up in storyboard, similar to
how we did with the label property.
And we can close our assistant editor
for now and focus on story board.
And then move this over a bit.
And to set our target action,
first we bring up the buttons
pop up connections menu,
go down to touch up inside,
drag to our View Controller, and choose
the method we want to be our action.
I'm just going to remove that
target action really quick so
I can show you how to
make it one other way.
Using the canvass view you can still
get to this menu, go from touch up
inside to the view controller and
then the method increment count and
you can see the three key
components of the target action.
Let's go ahead and run it so
we can see it in action and
if we click on the button we
can see our count incrementing.
So that ought to take
care of click counter.